- That guy looks like Napoleon Dynamite,
the one next to him, yeah, that one
looks like Napoleon Dynamite.
(laughing)
That's as close as we're getting.
(dynamic upbeat music)
- I do not think I know the '90s at all.
- I think I'm gonna do terrible.
No, I'm excited for this.
- Gosh, the '90s, you probably,
she probably doesn't--
- I think I know more than him.
I don't think I know a lot,
but I know more than him.
- Yeah, I don't know
if I'm gonna know any.
- I might be able to name one,
but let's see what happens.
- Wow! (laughing)
I don't know, one of
those boy bands, right,
like Boyz to Men, Backstreet Boys,
am I close, am I in the ballpark?
- First thing that popped in
my head was the Beach Boys,
but I'm fairly certain that's wrong.
- Oh.
- Oh, familiar.
- I have no clue.
- I think I know it, yeah, I know it.
Backstreet Boys?
Or NSYNC, one of the two.
Okay, yeah, that was my first guess.
- I've never even heard of them.
- NSYNC.
- I knew it was a boy band.
- He looks familiar, curly
hair, is that Justin Timberlake?
- [Both] It is?
- That's Justin, no, you're lying to me.
- I did not know that.
- He looks so much better now.
- Oh, God, yeah.
- She also looks familiar.
I don't know her name.
First guess that I would have to give,
I know it's completely wrong,
kind of reminds me of Kelly Clarkson.
- I like her lipstick.
Friends?
- I know her from Blended.
- Also Blended, yeah.
The one with Adam Sandler.
- Adam Sandler.
- Adam Sandler and Terry Crews,
I can't think of her name though.
- I have no clue who.
- Yeah,
there's no chance I'm
gonna guess it either.
Oh, okay.
- I knew that!
- I've heard the name before.
- I don't know why I didn't get that.
- Don't know the movie and
I don't know the actor.
A sad movie.
- I mean, that'd be my guess,
but it's also probably--
- Horror.
- Yeah, no, you're probably right there.
Yeah, that looks--
- It just seems like a boy,
that would be in a horror movie.
- Yeah, he definitely looks like he would.
- This is the kid who's like,
"I talk to ghosts," right?
Or Home Alone, I don't know,
it's the ghost kid, right?
Sixth Sense, Sixth Sense.
Yeah.
- That's a boy band, 'cause
they're all like posing
like they're in a boy band,
like a really bad album cover.
I'm also gonna say Beach
Boys, I know it's wrong.
I think that it might have been the '60s.
I know.
- Definitely--
- Sing.
- Yeah, either sing.
- They seem like a boy band.
- That or another random
'90's movie that's never seen.
- Boyz to Men.
Backstreet Boys.
Yeah, we already said NSYNC, okay.
- Is it Backstreet Boys?
Yeah, yeah.
- Oh, my gosh,
I was thinking of that, why didn't I say,
'cause that's the only thing I know,
but I was like, oh, maybe
it's from like 2000.
Dang it, I knew that!
Why have I seen him, I
feel like I've seen him.
- He's been in movies lately,
but I can't think of his name
or any movies he's been in.
- I've seen him,
I don't know who he is,
- Yeah, I've definitely
seen his face before.
- but I've seen him.
- He looks like he's a sitcom star maybe.
He kinda looks like the
guy who played Willy Wonka,
like a little bit, that
smile is a little weird.
- I've no clue who that is.
I've heard the name before.
- [Ethan] Seen her face multiple times.
- I don't know who that
is either, oh my gosh.
- That looks so familiar.
I've definitely seen a
movie or a show she's in.
- Oh, I've only heard
that like in a reference,
like pop culture reference,
I've never seen that movie.
- I've heard the name before,
don't know who she is.
- She looks like a young
version of someone I know now.
Like she looks like, I
feel like I've seen her
and she's old, but I don't know her young.
- Wow, you're so mean.
But yeah, no, I understand
what you're saying
and I completely agree.
- Seems very familiar, but
I don't know who she is.
Was the movie Oceans Eight?
She was?
- You're gonna hate me for asking this,
but is that the girl
from the Bird Box movie?
Oh, I'm so sad, that's
like how I know her,
'cause I know I should know her as like,
I know she has a lot better roles, but.
Sandra Bullock.
I'm feeling good about myself today.
- Oh, Sandra Bullock,
she's really talented.
- I have no idea who that is,
I haven't even like seen that before.
- Seems like a Mike, a Mike or an Adam.
So I wasn't even close.
- Yeah, no.
- Is he, he's alive?
- Oh.
- Don't know who that is,
she's either an actress
or a model or a dancer,
she seems very like fit
and athletic.
- I have no idea, I
don't wanna just sit here
and stare at the photo.
- Who?
- Oh, I've heard of her, yeah.
- [Nia] I've never.
- Mom listens to her music,
she's a singer.
- Mom's like 40 something.
- A singer, yeah.
- I don't know who she listens to.
- Yeah.
- This seems like a cop
show, like good cop, bad cop,
but the good cop is the guy
and the bad cop is the girl
and they're about to go
like infiltrate a home.
Crimes.
Crime scenes, is this
Crime Scene Investigation?
- Doh doh, you know, like the
crime shows, Law and Order,
no, wait, that was the doh doh show.
Saw.
BuzzFeed Unsolved.
(laughing)
Oh yeah, I was getting there.
- I've never even heard of it.
- It's still on the air,
it's on the air, but
it's completely rebooted.
- I've never even heard of it,
I really feel like I'm 13 right now.
- Yeah.
- I feel so young.
- Yeah, a lot of people just
never seen before in my life.
- He's an actor, kind of looks annoying,
but I don't know who he is.
- Is it Justin Timberlake again?
Alright, I'd be really upset
if you guys pulled that one on me.
- Really?
- Who's Cinnabon?
- Simba.
- Oh, Simba.
- Did you say?
- I never--
- How am I related to you?
- I've never seen him.
I know this one.
- [Nia] Oh.
- I've seen it before.
- I haven't.
- God, I know the guy
from multiple movies.
- I don't.
- Which guy?
- Middle.
- The old guy?
- I can't think of his name.
- Yeah, the guy in the front
seems like that annoying
looking kid from before.
Ah.
- Oh, yeah.
No, I've seen Bad Santa.
(laughing)
That movie's funny.
- Yeah, I know who she is.
- Oh.
- [Ethan] I can't do her name, but I can--
- [Nia] She looks
familiar, that's the thing.
- She's been in,
something recent.
She played a Mom in some show.
- A Mom?
- I know exactly.
- You got this.
- I can't think of the show or movie.
- She played Veronica in Heathers.
Yes, I have.
- Winona Ryder.
She was in Heathers.
Right, yeah.
I like her.
- That's where it was.
- Oh,
that's where we've seen her.
Oh, but she has like such short hair.
- Yeah.
- Awesome, we did it.
Pretty well.
- Awful, I'm surprised I
knew at least one person.
Apparently I knew the characters
more than I knew the actors.
- I did way better than
I thought I was going to.
- Oh, I thought I did awful.
- I didn't think I was gonna--
- I know,
I thought I would do so much better,
I didn't know any names, I
recognized so many people.
- I wanna be like really
cheesy and be like,
we all build over time
and it's good to learn about our past,
but like do I care?
No.
(light upbeat music)